the heroes of Wayne on YouTube premium
go on one wild journey over the course
of the show's rollicking first season
where do their adventures leave them and
what might happen to them next this is
the ending of lane explained before you
start watching the series the named
Wayne makes the show sound like it could
be about basically anything but by the
time the first season is over it feels
like a title that tells you all you need
to know what's the show about
well it's about that kid Wayne that
absolute madman the Robin Hood Meets
Dirty Harry of Brockton Massachusetts
how else could you describe it neither
hero nor antihero the protagonist of
Wayne is more like a force of nature a
teenage dispenser of violent justice
whose reputation precedes him everywhere
he goes his legend grows with his
enemies being left bruised bloodied or
in the case of Dell's daddy with their
nose half bitten off but no matter how
mythical Wayne is he's far from the
show's only focus the second half of the
equation is his classmate del which is
definitely not short for nothing so
don't ask the two teams are bonded by a
traumatic HomeLife social outcast status
and a tendency to talk with the heaviest
Boston accents in the history of the
East Coast
I don't suppose Wayne and del spend the
majority of the season making their way
down the East Coast to Ocala Florida
supposedly for the purpose of retrieving
a gold Trans Am that used to belong to
Wayne's late father the car is the
closest thing Wayne has to a birthright
being put together with real passion by
his dad before it was lost to Wayne's
absentee mother Maureen
since then it's ended up in the
possession of Curtis and Reggie the
hellishly criminal father and son duo
she ends up living with down south at
the start of the series getting the car
back makes for such a thin motivation to
cross the country that it almost feels
like a part of the show's big joke but
when Wayne and del actually arrive in
Ocala near the Seasons Inn it quickly
becomes clear to del that Wayne came all
this way for reasons more emotional than
he had first revealed he doesn't just
want a family heirloom he wants family
if he can get the trans am back from
Reggie his dirtbag stepbrother if you
can even really call him bat then all
the better as capable as he is on his
own wayne is still just a teenager
looking for somewhere to belong
he's so desperate for it that he drive
across the country to seek affection and
acceptance from the mother who abandon
him when he was only five so what if she
lives in as Dell calls it a white-trash
Fortress of meth heads and crocodiles
after Wayne's dad dies she and her
horrid new family are all he has left
Wayne never talks about any of this of
course though he's not what you'd call
nervous around people Wayne is a
definite introvert keeping his emotions
and thoughts guarded at pretty much all
times arriving with Dell in Florida is
the first time that he really shows any
vulnerability and his mother's such a
terrible person that the effort doesn't
really pay off at the start of the show
many of Wayne's Brockton based
antagonists like police sergeant Keller
and Dells dad and brothers see only
malicious evil in Wayne's behavior they
make assumptions of his character based
on the trail of broken bones and blood
he tends to leave behind him as they
follow his tracks toward Florida Wayne's
pursuers think that he's a madman in a
bad way at first they figure he
kidnapped del a somewhat reasonable
assumption considering the barbaric
level of damage he inflicted on Del's
family but when they start asking
questions to people who've met Wayne and
stayed on his good side they uncover a
different take on the fugitive team
Wayne is feared by his enemies sure but
he's motivated solely by a desire to do
good no matter how bad life treated here
a betrayed yeah from where I'm sitting
everything you do it's done out of love
the source of Wayne's chaotic good
nature comes out in ocala when Wayne is
catching up with his mother and her new
family for the first time in more than a
decade we learned from Mo's
recollections that Wayne is following in
the footsteps of his father who was
something of a hometown legend himself
as a younger man Wayne's father MO
explains always had a certain code of
honor along with the notorious intensity
known to drive neighbors out of town
everything was always black and white
with him she says right or wrong with no
middle ground sure sounds familiar
doesn't it just like that we finally
learned almost everything we need to
know about why Wayne is the way he is
it's a little bit of nature and a little
bit of nurture or the lack thereof at
the end of the show's first season Wayne
and Del's trail of destruction finally
catches up with them sorry
Geller manages to arrest Wayne with
arrangements being made to send him back
to Brockton to face the justice system
Dell tries to escape with Wayne but her
father and brothers catch up with them
to stopping them in their tracks and
successfully shepherding her away from
him whether she likes it or not the
season seems to end with both
protagonists at a personal low having
been captured by everything they were
trying to run away from Dell is back
with her terrible family and Wayne is
incarcerated probably not for the last
time in his life but while their
physical circumstances at the season's
end may be less than ideal both
characters have grown emotionally
becoming better people than they've ever
been before on a personal level Wayne
ends the last episode in an almost
triumphant place after the death of his
father he migrated south to see if he
could find a new home with family there
instead they all took turns trying to
kill each other while his mother sipped
wine now Wayne knows what the real score
is his future is not with family his
salvation is with del check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]